this is a Fox News Alert good evening
good morning here in Vietnam I'm Bret
Baier we are again coming to you halfway
around the world in Hanoi Vietnam where
the second summit between President
Trump and North Korean leader Kim
jong-un ended in a very different
fashion than the first without an
agreement this time President Trump says
he was not willing to give in to North
Korea's demand that the u.s. lift all
sanctions without an ironclad promise
from Kim to eliminate its nuclear
arsenal the North Koreans held an
extremely rare press conference a few
hours ago to say they only wanted some
of the sanctions lifted to get rid of
its biggest nuclear site the two leaders
canceled a scheduled lunch and signing
ceremony today back home both Democrats
and Republicans were giving the
president varying degrees of credit for
not giving in but in South Korea's
capital the collapse of the talks was
viewed with real disappointment
we have Fox team coverage read Calcott
is in Seoul South Korea where the
country's news agency says the security
situation has now turned back to zero
from the Trump administration resolve
about this decision and perhaps optimism
about the future even without another
meeting set up on the calendar we start
off here in Hanoi with chief White House
correspondent John Roberts hello John
rath good morning to you we are now at a
game of dueling diplomatic narratives
with both sides blaming the other for
the failure of the second u.s. North
Korea summit and president Trump getting
some support from an unlikely corner
the body language between President
Trump and Kim jong-un looked promising
but when it came down to the nuts and
bolts of negotiation president Trump
walked away from the table
I could have signed an agreement today
and then you people would have said oh
what a terrible deal what a terrible
thing he did now you have to be prepared
to walk kim jeong-hoon offered to close
the sprawling Jung Byung nuclear
facility the prime source of fissile
material for North Korea's nuclear
weapons program but in exchange
according to president Trump he wanted
all of the sanctions against the regime
lifted Leong beyond facility and all of
its scope which is important for sure
still leaves missiles still leaves
warheads and weapon systems they were
willing to dhenuka large portion of the
areas that we wanted but we couldn't
give up all of the sanctions for that at
a rare midnight press conference in
Hanoi North Korea's foreign minister
disputed the president's proposal in an
even more rare moment of agreement with
the president the Democratic leadership
said he was right to walk away chuck
schumer tweeting a deal that fell short
of complete denuclearization would have
only made north korea stronger and the
world less safe and this from House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi really it's good
that the president did not give him
anything for the little that he was
proposing it would typically be unheard
of for an American president to travel
halfway around the world to make a deal
than have it fall apart but there is no
playbook for a leader to leader
engagement with North Korea I think
everyone had hoped we could do it just a
little bit better
but the departure was with an agreement
that we would continue to work on what
has been an incredibly difficult problem
what comes
next is unclear President Trump says the
summit came to a premature close on
friendly terms this was in a walk away
like you get up and walk out now this
was very friendly we shook hands the
president continued his praise of Kim
jong-un and at one point appeared to
absolve him of any complicity in the
death of otto warmbier I don't believe
he knew about it speak to him he felt
very badly he knew the case very well
but he knew it later but even lawmakers
who backed the president's decision to
walk away from the table found that one
hard to swallow
nabil i'm kim jung-soo kim jeongmin lied
i mean he had to know nothing happens
that comes with that didn't know why
both sides are expected to keep talking
president Trump made no prediction as to
win the next summit with kim jeong-hoon
might be the president said at his press
conference it could be soon maybe not
for a long time certainly something for
Kim to think about right John Roberts
just down the road here in Hanoi John
thanks